la buona sera a tutti dalla realtà
artificiale di federico vi riporto sulla
realtà quotidiana invece di quello che
succede tutti i giorni
guardando la televisione aprendo i
giornali su internet siamo ovviamente
invasi tutti i giorni da tantissime
notizie
io nella mia professione mi sono quasi
esclusivamente ecco occupata di cronaca
sia da inviato prima da vice
caporedattore adesso ma capire quanto
l'intuizione conti nel nostro lavoro
nella professione del giornalista vale
ovviamente in tutti i campi
dall'informazione politica economica
sociale e culturale
io ovviamente vi parlo di quella che
alla mia esperienza personale lo dicevo
prima il giornalismo si basa sui fatti
significa da una parte raccontare la
realtà i fatti che succedono che abbiamo
lì davanti a noi e poi cercare di capire
le cause di quella realtà dall'altra
significa andare a scoprire anche le
realtà più nascoste e lì c'è il
giornalismo d'inchiesta andare a scavare
andare ad approfondire tutto questo
succede in tutte le redazioni nella
carta stampata per la radio per la
televisione per internet per tutti i
mezzi di informazione è un lavoro dunque
che molto concreto che si basa sui fatti
dove però l'intuizione è molto
importante
vi farò alcuni esempi
in alcuni casi il fatto è eclatante cioè
la notizia è lì davanti a noi
impossibile da non vedere e quindi
teoricamente molto più facile da
raccontare
un esempio su tutti lo avrete presente
lo ricorderete la costa concordia il
naufragio della costa concordia davanti
all'isola del giglio la nave appena
naufragata era lì davanti a tutti quindi
come dire un fatto semplice da un primo
punto di vista da raccontare io quel
giorno ero
responsabile della redazione cronaca la
mattina subito dopo il naufragio
e vi racconta appunto come ci si
comporta in questi casi la prima cosa da
fare ovviamente davanti a un fatto così
importante è fare subito partire gli
inviati cioè i colleghi che vanno sul
posto e che ci raccontano che cosa sta
succedendo quello che vedono che
raccolgono le testimonianze delle
persone dei sopravvissuti ma dopo aver
fatto queste prime cose che di solito
appunto sono le cose che si fanno nella
prima emergenza che cosa qui scatta la
domanda che cosa possiamo fare in più
per riuscire a trovare qualcosa che vada
al di là del semplice racconto di quello
che è successo
ecco
e qui entra in gioco l'intuizione cioè
cosa posso raccontare di più per fare
capire maggiormente quello che sta
succedendo
per esempio
poche ore dopo il naufragio della
concordia quasi tutti avevano già a
disposizione ovviamente le immagini
della nave
ve la ricordate no posata su un fianco
davanti all'isola del giglio i primi
racconti dei sopravvissuti cioè di tutti
i passeggeri che ormai erano stati
tratti in salvo e portati a terra un
primo bilancio delle vittime e dei
dispersi che poi ovviamente nel corso
dei giorni
è aumentato a questo punto ecco dopo
qualche ora dal naufragio voi avete
queste cose che cosa vi manca
vi faccio una domanda avete le immagini
della nave avete il racconto dei primi
sopravvissuti avete un primo bilancio
delle persone che mancano all'appello
quindi delle vittime e dei dispersi
che cosa vi manca di che cosa sentite di
aver bisogno
le cause poi è quello ovviamente cercare
le cause no ci vorrà tempo per capirlo
ovviamente cos'altro vi manca un altro
elemento
le testimonianze celle ai cioè i
sopravvissuti sono arrivati a terra che
hanno raccontato cosa è successo quella
notte
ecco a noi è venuto cosa ci manca in
quel momento a me è venuto in mente
questo mi mancano le immagini da dentro
la nave le immagini che mi raccontino
quei momenti in cui sono ci sono stati
gli avvisi a bordo e non si capiva che
cosa stesse succedendo le persone che
salivano sulle scialuppe di salvataggio
quello è stata l'intuizione a quel punto
con una collega ho detto dobbiamo
cercare qualcuno dei sopravvissuti che
ovviamente abbia girato qualcosa visto
che adesso con i telefonini no giriamo
immagini in qualsiasi situazione e
quindi siamo è stato un lavoro non
facile perché all'inizio sembra scontato
no nei giorni successivi ve lo
ricorderete siamo invasi siamo stati
invasi da immagini riprese a bordo della
nave ma nelle prime ore è stato molto
difficile ci siamo riusciti e la sera
stessa ecco della del primo giorno del
naufragio siamo riusciti a mandare in
onda questi primi frammenti con le voci
di
drammatiche di quei momenti le possiamo
vedere
e tutta d'attacco era pagata
un'altra così proprio tutta scivoli
tavoli bicchieri i camerieri corelli
tutti viene davvero
alla luce spenta
marroncina gioca anche bene
l'uomo che abbiamo alcuni momenti ripido
lega
un quarto
ma quelli della nave che mi dicevano non
c'è
nessuna premier ha pure registrato
perché ho detto e qui ci dicono che
tutto bene registrati
recchia
piega davvero
cosa che non l'hanno potuto togliere le
scialuppe per colmare savino vento
l'acqua
da un'altra parte anno di fondo della
quattro mappe sarà un senso deviando
adesso se diventassi alla fine siamo
andati b e c hanno ucciso poi ci
avessero mai 3 su siamo venti figure
vantaggio perché scalare chiave che
lasciano da morire
va bene
aga
mi ha capita
l'aduc se saranno salvati gli alunni ad
eto'o sarà meglio che rimaneva molin
perché sia stata gira pure ma c'è un pò
se stava gira non sappiamo ha notata una
tripla ma che fai
tutti i duri che siamo stati così ho
dato morte che bello quello guarda qui
vado mi è sembrato salir titaniche è
inaffondabile gli ho detto io
è questo però deve essere
inaffondabilità futuro in mezz'ora punta
d'amore le racconto un po così dopo la
signora cerca di sdrammatizzare quello
che è successo è stata appunto la
signora con la sua testimonianza
lei con la sua macchina fotografica che
ha girato questo questo video quindi
ecco quello della concordia un esempio
di come sia importante avere un
intuizione un'idea un momento prima
degli altri poi sono arrivati tutti gli
altri sono arrivati tutti gli altri
video ci sono altri casi in cui entra in
gioco l'intuizione intuizione anche
capire da poche righe da una piccola
notizia da un piccolo trafiletto su un
giornale locale che quel tema diventerà
importante che si guadagnerà la prima
pagina dei giornali e vi faccio un altro
esempio vi ricorderete quest'estate
questo è un caso molto recente il il
caso scoppiato sulla processione di
oppido mamertina in calabria quando la
statua fu fatta fermare davanti alla
casa di un boss in segno di omaggio alla
al boss del paese
ecco all'inizio questa notizia è uscita
come un piccolo trafiletto su un
giornale locale
poi qualche giorno dopo addirittura
quindi non il giorno stesso ma un
giornale nazionale lo ha pubblicato sul
suo sito online la mattina era molto
basso quindi insomma non tra le notizie
più importanti poi nel corso della
giornata a questa notizia è salita come
diciamo noi in gergo è diventata una
notizia nazionale è scoppiato poi tutta
la polemica che
vi ricorderete un altro caso importante
è un caso di cronaca degli ultimi anni
tutti ricorderete la vicenda della morte
di stefano cucchi proprio martedì scorso
è iniziato il processo d'appello
qui a roma ecco la morte improvvisa di
stefano con gli evidenti segni di
percosse sul corpo fu segnalata la
nostra redazione proprio il giorno
stesso della sua morte da un avvocato
dall'avvocato che si era occupato di un
altro caso importante quello di federico
aldrovandi il ragazzo morto a ferrara
ecco il caporedattore che in quel
momento appunto stava lavorando ha avuto
l'intuizione che
dell'importanza di quella segnalazione a
di cui nessuno ovviamente notizia di cui
nessuno parlava perché non era uscita su
nessuna agenzia di stampa da nessuna
parte ha assegnato alla il caso ad un
collega che ha contattato la sorella di
stefano ilaria cucchi e abbiamo così
raccolto proprio il giorno dopo la morte
di stefano il 23 ottobre del 2009
la denuncia della sorella vediamo
quest'altro video mio fratello era un
ragazzo di 31 anni che la notte tra
giovedì e venerdì della settimana scorsa
è stato arrestato in una zona di roma
per detenzione di sostanze stupefacenti
e l'epilogo è stato che ieri abbiamo
avuto la notizia del suo decesso presso
l'ospedale pertini di roma reparto
carcerario
cioè lui è in carcere quando è morto
praticamente sì lei ha visto il suo
corpo
io l'ho visto qui all'obitorio si dietro
un vetro e che cosa ha visto è una cena
indescrivibile
il viso completamente
ti hanno disegni di lividi aveva un
occhio fuori dalle orbite aveva la
mascella visibilmente rotta
e non ho visto il corpo perché il corpo
era coperto dalle lenzuola
quindi lei sospetta fortemente che
societario sia stato picchiato in
carcere da solo non se ne ha fatte
quelle cose
quindi quando suo fratello è stata stato
stava bene i suoi genitori l'hanno visto
assolutamente sì voi siete andati a
trovarlo in ospedale noi siamo andati a
trovarlo in ospedale ma ovviamente
nessuno ci ha saputo o voluto dire nulla
non ci davano alcun tipo di notizie la
sposerà che quello era un carcere non si
poteva assolutamente dare nessuna
notizia
io vorrei giustizia vorrei chiarezza
perché da solo mio fratello quelle cose
non se l'è fatte qualcuno ha sbagliato
qualcuno deve pagare assolutamente dopo
questa intervista
ovviamente il caso è diventato un caso
nazionale e appunto come ho detto il
processo è ancora
abbiamo visto solo alcuni esempi di come
una notizia possa nascere da
un'intuizione questo succede dovrebbe
succedere a meno tutti i giorni in ogni
redazione
a volte può bastare anche un frammento
di una notizia di un'informazione
ricevuta a volte anche involontariamente
da cui partire a quel punto l'intuizione
poi ci porta ad approfondire a quel
giornalismo d'inchiesta di cui di cui
parlavo all'inizio andare a scavare e
trovare le informazioni nascoste e poi
arrivare anche in alcuni casi a degli
scoop come li chiamiamo noi no quando si
riesce a trovare la notizia veramente
importante se secondo alcuni esperti di
media internazionali l'intuizione sarà
uno degli aspetti sempre più importanti
nel giornalismo del futuro ormai
dominato dalle nuove tecnologie e quindi
dalla velocità con cui arrivano le
notizie praticamente in tempo in tempo
reale ecco ma come può nascere
un'intuizione nel nostro campo nella
nostra professione oggi li abbiamo visti
in tanti altri campi ovviamente serve
esperienza serve un'adeguata formazione
serve leggere tantissimo ecco non solo i
titoli dei giornali online serve leggere
il vecchio giornale cartaceo di carta
che ormai nessuno quasi compra più
perché nei piccoli trafiletti nelle
piccole notizie si può nascondere quella
che domani sarà la notizia del giorno ma
soprattutto io questo lo ripeto sempre
ai colleghi ma soprattutto ai più
giovani che cominciano a fare questo
lavoro serve la curiosità questa è la
cosa alla base del nostro lavoro la
curiosità di cercare di capire di
chiedere di cercare di andare oltre
oggi vi racconto solo brevemente
quest'ultimo così la cosa che mi è
capitata oggi a pranzo eravamo seduti
con un'altra collega e avevamo di fronte
due ragazzi parlando
una ragazza ci ha detto di essere una
neolaureata in una
in un corso di laurea che io non
conoscevo scienze per le tecnologie per
la conservazione dei beni culturali
una cosa che quasi nessuno conosce in
italia a sta lavorando ad un progetto
interessantissimo su un laser che serve
per appunto applicato a
tutte le opere d'arte per cercare
appunto di prevenire quella che
all'invecchiamento per dare lo stato dei
colori insomma un meccanismo molto
complesso che però viene usato
pochissimo è quasi sconosciuto in italia
questo laser sta per essere smontato mi
diceva la ragazza perché non ci sono i
fondi e questo mi si è accesa la famosa
lampadina detto bear dobbiamo parlarne
dammi il numero di telefono perché
adesso il tg3 se ne vorrà occupare cioè
cerchia no
parlando da da piccole conversazioni
possono nascere poi delle notizie
speriamo insomma che anche questa possa
essere una notizia da far da far
conoscere fuori quindi vi dicevo la
curiosità è stato già citato
precedentemente la scena dell'attimo
fuggente con il professore che invita
gli studenti a salire sui banchi per
vedere la realtà da un altro punto di
vista questo serve e vorrei chiudere con
questo serve per far nascere
l'intuizione vorrei chiudere con una
citazione di marcel proust che diceva la
vera scoperta non consiste nel trovare
nuovi territori ma nel vederli con nuovi
occhi ed è lì che scatta all'intuizione
grazie a tutti